It is time for Drew's News.
If news programs were sensations,
we'd be that feeling you get
when you pull off your panty hose.
(sighs)
What?
With me at the desk
he's got legs and he knows how to use 'em,
Rossy Ross Mathews.
Hi everybody.
Pull off your pantyhose?
(audience applauds)
Can we talk about your halfsy updo?
How cute this is?
I feel like you are cheerleader
and I'm about to ask you to prom.
That's what I feel like.
(audience applauds)
I do feel like I'm channeling
a little inner Sydney Sweeney.
Cute.
You know,
Sydney Sweeney from White Lotus, Euphoria?
She's like,
Yes.
She's gonna be in the new Black Widow
with Dakota Johnson, love her.
She came on the show,
love her.
She did.
Well, first up today in our news,
Vogue's May cover girl,
the stunning mom to be, Rihanna.
That's right.
(audience applauds)
When she got pregnant, Rihanna says that she knew one thing,
She'd never see a maternity aisle,
because she loves to dress up.
She talks about the father of the baby,
her partner, A$AP Rocky,
and she says she doesn't let guys
out of the friend zone easy.
And she's known him for a decade
but everything changed over the pandemic
when they took a road trip, just the two of them,
across the country in a tour bus.
Oh God.
Mm-hm.
She's not sure if she's having a baby shower
but if she does, it'll be co-ed with cocktails.
She says she wants people to leave plastered
and crawling out.
Yes.
God, she is everything.
Everything.
(audience applauds)
Rihanna.
There's so much,
there's so much to break down.
One, I wanna go to that baby shower and get drunk.
Yes!
Two,
interesting that they were friends
and got out of the friend zone.
She doesn't wanna wear maternity clothes.
All I wanna wear is maternity clothes!
That stuff looks so,
elastic jeans?
Sign me up.
Yeah, you were...
You make kaftans.
Thank you very much for knowing that.
I do, I have one.
And then also,
who wants to go on a road trip with Rihanna now?
Right? Doesn't that sound fun?
(audience cheers and applauds)
I feel like,
do you think, on a road trip, she's like,
"shut up and drive", (laughs) so stupid.
(Drew laughs)
It's a Rihanna song.
We went on a road trip together.
I dig everything about her.
I do love that she's completely flipping the script
on maternity style.
Totally.
She shows the bump.
It's skin tight.
It's bare.
She's stylish.
She really, like...
I have to say, I really loved my pregnant stomach,
'cause it was the first time my stomach was tight.
(audience laughs)
I'm not kidding.
That is so funny.
Not even joking a little.
Really.
I should have sported it out more.
And I feel like she's given all women license
to ditch the norms and the confines
of what we think we're supposed to dress like
as pregnant women.
Yeah.
Also, I have Intel about the Rihanna shoot.
That's right.
My daughter's beautiful stepmother, Allie works at Vogue
and I asked her, was there any insider information?
And she says, apparently, the baby was kicking like crazy
through the whole shoot.
So when you see the cover, think of that yummy moment.
How great is that?
Thanks Allie.
So cute.
I know.
Ross, your story.
All right.
Well next up, we have a controversial new dating concept.
Are you ready for this?
DMarge reports the new trend is called "tryst timing",
"tryst timing", and here's how it works.
People are going on dates and beforehand,
they secretly set a timer on their phone
to set off a ring tone exactly 37 minutes into the date.
So your phone will go off
but it'll ring like someone's calling you, right?
So if the date is a total horror show
you have an escape hatch, right?
So you can say like, "Oh, I'm so sorry.
It was my landlord and I, oh what?
Oh, there's a leak!
I have to go."
(audience giggles)
On the other hand, if the date is going well,
the phone can ring and you can be like,
"You know what?
I'm gonna ignore this,
'cause I'm really feeling this", right?
Which gives you brownie points.
Is it diabolical or is it smart?
Oh, I don't know.
Who likes this concept?
Show of hands.
Raise 'em up.
I wanna know, 'cause it helps me.
I mean, I'll always be my own person at the end of the day
but I do like decisions by committee.
Yeah.
Um, okay.
Yeah, I like one half of this.
Which half?
One half of you're,
"I'm having such a good time.
I'd love to not take this call."
That is sweet
and I like sweet.
I, although I suppose I am a professional actor,
I cannot do this, I can't pull it off.
You can't fake it?
Hell no.
Really?
Here's what I, here's what I do, call me.
Okay, ring, ring, ring, ring, hello?
Anything that resembles a phone, okay.
(audience laughs)
You need to hold it up.
Hello, Drew?
Hello?
Hi.
Oh, there's a leak, you gotta leave.
There's a leak?
(audience laughs)
You're so bad.
I know!
Oh yeah, it's bad.
You gotta get home right now.
Oh my God, okay.
Oh, uh, um.
"There's an emergency and I'm so sorry and..."
And then I'll be there for the next 10 minutes
trying to explain and apologize.
(audience laughs)
Yeah.
And this, I can't,
I can't do this.
I can't pull these-
No
These ruses off.
(bright theme music)